i have to tell you
i don't normally take great pleasure in
this type of thing
but i took great pleasure in lunatic
republican laura loomer sobbing while
claiming that the election was stolen
from her
by a republican we're going to look at
the video in a moment it is really
something else if you're not familiar
with laura loomer
laura loomer was a far-right
congressional candidate she was running
first and foremost in florida in a
primary against daniel webster okay
she ran a primary against daniel webster
and she lost the primary
this is florida's 11th congressional
district laura loomer 29 years old
complete and total extremist
and um she lost and she just she just
lost there's there's really nothing else
to it
um this is a republican stronghold
district the republican party has
received at least 65 percent of the vote
in the last three elections
in 2020 loomer won a primary in
florida's 21st district but was then
crushed in what is an unfavorable
district if she had won this week she
probably would have won the general
because now she was running in a very
conservative district but daniel webster
won
and there's this incredible video where
she is sobbing and saying fraud cost her
the win and i have to tell you that to
some degree i find this absolutely
hilarious
we are losing our country because of big
tech election interference and i am
pleading with the republican party to
please start taking this issue seriously
please
because the american people deserve
representation and that's that's why i
ran for congress in 2020 it's why i ran
for congress in 2022 and it's why i'm
going to keep fighting for all of you
yeah so she's asking republicans to stop
the voter fraud in a republican primary
in a red district completely run by
republicans so i guess it's really not
democrats that are doing the voter fraud
and of course if you actually confront
them with that and you say wait you guys
spent the second half of 2020
arguing that it's democratic voter fraud
that's going to result in the theft of
an election and it was the democratic
machine that stole it from trump and
gave it to biden
but now they lose a republican primary
and they use the exact same series of
talking points so it's democrats and
republicans and then they'll say yeah
it's the rhino republicans the the the
rhino republicans which means republican
in name only they're not really
republicans
they are just as bad with the voter
fraud so but in 2020 a lot of those
rhinos won
but you didn't say there was voter fraud
then no well in 2020 it was just the
democrats but then now it's the
republicans in the primaries
this is absurd and it is a great thing
that laura loomer lost laura loomer has
promoted mass shooting conspiracies like
for example claiming parkland was staged
the vegas shooter was isis she claimed a
right winger who was arrested for having
illegal weapons was actually antifa she
described herself as a pro-white
nationalist so i think you get it this
is an absolutely completely and totally
horrible person and then she put out a
statement on some platform saying she
doesn't concede and it's crazy she wrote
i do not concede
and i encourage all of my supporters and
all of my voters to not support daniel
webster and the corrupt establishment
rnc
and the big tech voter fraud machine
that is propping his feeble body up and
depriving my constituents of the
representation they deserve a need i'm
calling for daniel webster to resign
because everyone knows he is beyond
unfit to serve um you know i think
that's a message i can actually get
behind if laura loomer is saying in
november in the 11th district don't go
out and vote for daniel webster you it's
a mostly republican district
i'm absolutely fine with them staying
home i would never advocate for people
not to vote i think
it's not a good thing to tell people
don't vote
but if they want to tell their
supporters not to vote i am absolutely
all for it it's hilarious that this is
what is going on with laura loomer and
deservedly so not that daniel webster is
that much better he's not he's no beauty
right to use donald trump's phraseology
but uh loomer would have been extremely
dangerous it is a great thing that she
lost she lost fair and square